I think when I was I don't know five or
six or something I thought I was insane
I know a lot of people like weed and
that's fine
but I don't find that it is very good
for productivity
what's that believe nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so today we're gonna get
inside the mind of Elon Musk learn about
why he thinks weed is bad and how his
brain works also if you want to know
what Elon Musk and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next two hundred and fifty four
days I will send you a morning video for
free to help you build your confidence
the link to join is in the description
below there are times when something is
important enough you believe it enough
that you do it in spite of the fear I am
NOT a regular smoker of weed how often
you smoke it almost never mmm I mean
it's it's I don't actually notice any
effect I know a lot of people like weed
and that's fine
but I don't find that it is very good
for productivity for you not for me yeah
it's didn't mean I would imagine that
for someone like you it's not someone
like you it'd be more like a cup of
coffee right you wanna you're at a yeah
it's more like the opposite of a cup of
coffee was like a cup of coffee in
Reverse Oh wheat is yeah no I'm saying
you would like more more like will be
beneficial to you would be like coffee I
like to get things done I like to be
useful but it's one of the hardest
things to do it'll be useful when you
say you'd like to get things done like
in terms of like what you value
satisfaction when you complete a project
when something something that you invent
comes to fruition and you see people
enjoying it that feeling
yes doing something useful for other
people that I like doing it that's
interesting for other people yes like
when you're thinking about things like
that is that like one of your
considerations like what what could I do
that would help people
yeah I'd be they wouldn't be able to
figure out yeah like like what are the
set of things that can be done to make
the future better like you know like so
I think that a future where we are
spacefaring civilization and out there
among the stars this is very exciting
this makes me look forward to the future
this makes me want that future you know
the things they need to be things that
make you look forward to waking up in
the morning you wake up in the morning
you look forward to the day forward to
the future a future where we are
spacefaring civilization and out there
among the stars I think that's very
exciting that is a thing we want where
as if if you knew we would not be a
spacefaring civilization but forever
confined to earth this would not be a
good future that would be very sad I
think if there are two futurists and one
futurists we're out there among the
stars and things we read about and see
in science fiction movies the good ones
are true we have these starships and
where we're going to see what the other
planets are like and we're a
multi-planet species and the scope and
scale of consciousness is expanded
across many civilizations and many
planets and many star systems this is a
great future this is a wonderful thing
to me and that's what we should strive
for view it seems like almost like
there's a franticness to your creativity
that comes out of this this burning
furnace and for in order for you to like
calm that thing down you go through you
might have to throw too much water on it
it's like a never-ending explosion like
what is it like I try to explain it to a
dumb person like me what's going on in
her never-ending explosion it's just
constant ideas just bouncing around yes
whoo damn yeah so when everybody leaves
it's just Elon sitting at home brushing
his teeth just bunch ideas bouncing
around in your head yeah
whole time when did you realize that
that's not the case with most people I
think when I was I don't know five or
six or something
I thought I was insane why'd you think
you're insane because it was clear that
other people do not what their mind
wasn't exploding with ideas all the time
they weren't expressing it they weren't
talking about it all day and you realize
by the time we were five or six like oh
they're probably not even getting this
thing that I'm getting no it was just
strange it was like hmm I'm strange what
my conclusion a strange but did you feel
diminished by it in any way like knowing
that this is a weird thing that you
really probably couldn't commiserate
with with other people they would they
wouldn't understand you know if they
wouldn't find out cuz they might like
put me away with something you thought
that for a second yes we were little and
the other people away what if they put
me away like when you were little you
thought this yes Wow like you thought
that this is so radically different than
the people that are around me if they
find out I got this stream coming in
yeah if you had to think of one word
that's most important to you or that
sums you Apple
that would be collect a little beacon if
you liked this video and want more Elon
Musk check out the top ten rules video I
did on him the link is right there next
to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there what was your biggest failure and
how did I change
to really think hard about the failure